how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course everything relating to the MCU we
have had a lot of updates recently
including rescheduling of the film's for
phase 4 and some phase 5 news we have a
lot of reports we have movies that are
going to be in development for phase 5
we have some news that some phase 5
movies are going to begin shooting very
soon and fortunately for us it looks
like Marvel Studios is back open for
business as we've gotten some reports
that production has began again on some
of the phase 4 projects so a lot to talk
about today specifically the phase 5
2023 lineup and a ton of other news as
well so I'll break it all down but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all things relating
to the MCU and so you can enter this
week's giveaway which is a Captain
America Avengers endgame Funko pop just
be sure to subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below so before it
kind of seemed like phase 5 had been
unveiled and for the most part we do
know a good majority of the movies that
are going to be on that phase 5 slate
what we don't know is the order of the
films and obviously there are going to
be some films announced that are going
to come out of left field that we
probably weren't even thinking about
Marvel and Kevin Feige have a great way
of doing that which is awesome and we
actually do have one film that is pretty
much confirmed to be a part of Phase
five in 2023 that we really weren't
expecting so soon in fact what we
believed to be the entire phase 5 lineup
for 2023 really isn't what we expected
at all but nonetheless we are all very
excited about it so the first thing that
you have to keep in mind about phase 5
and about how the mind of Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios works is
that they plan years and years in
advance after Kevin Feige unveiled the
phase 4 lineup he said that they have
the next five years planned out con
creat and they probably have the next 10
years planned out but it's not concrete
yet
meaning that phase six and possibly
seven could still obviously change
depending on what happens but they plan
things out way in advance which means
the first part of Phase five 2023 has
been planned out probably for at least a
few years meaning unfortunately there
probably isn't going to be an x-men
movie any type of solo x-men films or
Fantastic Four film in 2023 and the
reason for that is again because Marvel
had been planning out phase 5 before
they got the rights back to the x-men
and the Fantastic Four but I'm just
specifically talking about 2023 s phase
5 lineup the Fantastic Four and the
x-men will be coming in phase 5 just not
in 2023 so for 2023 who do we have well
based off of everything that we know and
based off of what a few insiders have
seen and reported the phase 5 slate for
2023 goes as follows ant-man 3 blade
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and Nova
and there's something very important to
note about these movies coming in 2023
they each serve a very specific purpose
when it comes to the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so let's talk
about what purpose each of these films
are going to play
we'll start with ant-man 3 because this
has been confirmed for a while and very
recently just this month only a few days
ago Michael Douglas Hank Pym himself was
doing a QA and he said this about
ant-man 3 and thank you too Bruce comic
fan for this video what can you tell us
about the status so as you can see since
ant-man 3 is going to be a part of 2023
phase 5 slate they've definitely already
started on a bunch of things it's most
likely in pre-production right now and
based off of what Michael Douglas has
said it seems like we may be finding
some more information about it soon but
the role that it's going to play is that
it's going to establish a very big
character in the MCU and this character
is most likely going to be a very
prominent villain now although we are
not 100% sure on just who this villain
is it is widely speculated to be Victor
Von Doom aka Doctor Doom if it is Doctor
Doom this obviously sets up the MCU in a
very huge way and if
course with dr. doom comes the Fantastic
Four who are also widely believed to
appear in some shape or form in ant-man
3 at least teased the biggest part about
ant-man 3 is going to be the quantum
realm we were advised from Marvel
themselves to look closely at a scene in
ant-man 2 where we saw a quantum city
the people from ant-man 2 expressed that
this city is going to play a very
important role in the future now we
thought it was going to be an Avengers
in game but it wasn't this means that
they have some type of plan for it in
ant-man 3 and what's in that quantum
city is going to be of great importance
it's either going to be the Fantastic
Four are stuck somehow in the quantum
realm and that's how they're going to
get their powers instead of their origin
and the comics from space Doctor Doom
could also be down there and Annihilus
or King the conquer could also be there
as well again although we are not 100%
sure this movie is going to be a staple
in phase 5 as far as setting up the
future of the MCU blade of course is
going to play another role in the future
of the MCU blade is going to kind of
open up a bit of a darker side to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the original
blade movies were rated R and although
the new blade coming with Marshall ollie
is most likely not going to be rated R
it is going to be dark and dr. strange
in the multiverse of madness is probably
going to segue into blade dr. strange is
supposed to be the MCS first horror type
film and again it won't be rated R but
we will more than likely see some type
of demon characters and that's where
blade comes in the quasi vampire
supernatural creature killer will expand
Marvel's monster universe and this will
be a new fresh take on the normal
superhero movies that we're all used to
kind of more of an adult type superhero
film but blade will set the road for
other films and characters like Ghost
Rider sons of midnight and of course the
Moon Knight series that is going to be
coming to Disney plus the other film
Nova is going to be a big part of the
cosmic feature of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and guardians of the galaxy
kind of goes hand-in-hand with them as
well at least for the origin of Nova now
a nova project was reported to be in
development about a week ago and at the
time when we reported it we didn't know
if it was going to be a film or a show
but now it seems like we have an
sir and that answer is a film according
to Vicki de pledged an editorial
journalist at the cinema spot that Nova
project is indeed going to be a film and
is most likely going to be a part of
phase fives 2023 movies now this is huge
because Marvel has been saying for a
while that the future is going to be in
the cosmos and Nova is a perfect
frontrunner to lead a cosmic team along
with Captain Marvel and of the guardians
of the galaxy along their adventures
now Marvel Studios already revealed that
they were going to put Nova in Avengers
infinity war they were actually going to
show the destruction of Xander and Nova
was actually going to take the spot of
the Hulk to warn earth
about Thanos now obviously that was
scrapped but it seems like Marvel
Studios have figured out another way to
bring Nova into the MCU simply by giving
him his own story in his own solo film
which of course he deserves and right
beside Nova is going to be guardians of
the galaxy now the future of the
guardians is currently unknown on
whether or not they're going to go past
a volume three however if nothing has
changed in Marvel's plans
guardians of the galaxy three will go on
to introduce Adam warlock and we know
that Marvel has big plans for Adam
because you don't introduce a character
as big as Adam warlock just for one
movie if you did it's essentially the
same as making Galactus a cloud everyone
will hate you for it but as I said
Marvel Studios plans things way far in
advance and according to a recent report
from Mikey Sutton Marvel has big plans
for Adam warlock coming up teaming up
with Captain Marvel and Nova so as you
can see these four movies that are
widely believed to be the face 5 slate
for 2023 are going to play a major role
in the future of the MCU each being very
very important however before phase 5
comes phase 4 and we have some good news
when it comes to phase 4 for the most
part it sounds like Marvel Studios is
almost running at full speed again they
are not 100% back to normal activity
because we are still in a pandemic but
things are slowly starting back up again
the UK has said that they can start
filming for shows such as the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier again this means that
Marvel when they choose to can get back
on track with
duction which means hopefully no more
delays in phase four
we got another report that says most of
the filming if not all of the filming
has been completed for the Wanda and
vision series and in fact it's been
reported that we could be getting a
trailer for both Wanda vision and the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier at this
year's San Diego Comic Con from home if
you are not aware San Diego Comicon will
be streaming this year instead of
cancelling Comic Con they're going to
still be doing their panels and they're
going to stream them so as soon as I
find out how exactly to watch I'll be
sure to make a video on it and lastly
but of course not least shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings has
reportedly been able to continue work
during the pandemic remotely and the
report says that they're not actually
too far behind if not behind at all
filming will have to continue but a lot
of editing and production has been done
during this pandemic remotely so great
news about Marvel phase four is going to
get back on track very soon and phase
five looks like it's going to be
absolutely fantastic but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below if these do in fact
get locked down for the phase 5 2023
slate are you excited for them be sure
to leave a comment down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU for live updates and
stupid memes you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof